I have a question yes so when you check
a girlfriend's email and you see fine
I've ever done it so I don't have a lot
of experience this is my question yeah
so this is the first and only time you
had done something like that and you
found stuff like so conclusive I was so
[ __ ] yeah how can you not check every
woman's email after that if you have
even a slight suspicion knowing that the
first time you did it you found just a
goldmine yeah
after that I still have some trust for
I've seen horrible female behavior
I probably mail too but I don't notice
that because I'm not into men you know
but like I've seen women at the comedy
store go to the bathroom [ __ ] a guy a
random comment to come back and say what
their boyfriend yes yeah yeah them and
they'd be all cuddly it like they just
got fun right right right
in the middle of a date you just ever
[ __ ] do that I know you I trust you
you'll never do it but when you know
they're capable I know but I know she's
not even capable but I'm gonna say it I
will cry for a year straight I will cry
for the I'm with you there I used to
live in Vegas and I had some seedy
friends who would [ __ ] a chick into
parking lot and then meet up with her
with their wives at the poker table and
I've seen this like time and time again
so I have that same feeling so you know
I'm somebody who's like a naturally
suspicious person and I have checked
let's say a boyfriend or a significant
others like email in the past and I've
found stuff before so like that carries
over into every single relationships the
practice that kind of restraint and say
even when you have a little bit of a
suspicion over someone and saying no
that's unhealthy I shouldn't fall into
that pit I shouldn't check it was really
really hard yeah yeah it is well after
that I sort of went through this thing
where I met it I met a girl before we
broke up I met a girl a commercial shoot
mmm she was a I think wardrobe the
Wardrobe people and the hair and makeup
people are the coolest people on
commercials I got style
they're just chill cool people and so I
usually hang out with them I wouldn't
hang out with like directors and stuff I
don't know I just wasn't that guy
anyway this girl was like cool we start
talking about like Quentin Tarantino she
was a fan so am i and he was she was
like do you know what he's bringing some
movie from from from Japan over here and
it's like I was like oh really it's good
we start talking about it like we should
go like yeah for sure
just friendly and then and then we kept
talking kept talking it was like five
hours of just talking all the time then
I start getting flirtier and uh but I
had that girlfriend etosha of the time
and then it was like and then I left was
like okay then I realized oh this is
gonna be a date for was just like
alright to people but now it's gonna be
I had to call him like hey I don't think
I can go with you cuz I got this
girlfriend she's like we could go just
his friends and was like yeah but I feel
like we sort of my past that already
yeah yeah yeah and then I find out that
you know she wasn't like cheating but
she was unfaithful let's say hmm and
then it was like fine I had a chance
with like this girl that I hit it off
with that I didn't go for what were
relationship it didn't go anywhere yeah
that was ending yeah I'm like that would
have been really nice so then I just
started going like I'm done with
monogamy mm-hmm I'm just like hey you
[ __ ] whoever you want I'm gonna [ __ ]
whoever I want I'm just not gonna get
jealous with you so my next girlfriend
it was like or two girls later was like
just open and so we were like let I'll
let you know if I got a date let me know
Aaron what was it Aaron no no that was
later Ali Ali yeah yeah yeah yeah I got
married in the belly room you know I
also had people like if Bobby comes so
we're not allowed I have people pacing
that door but like and so then it's just
like you know if you're on a date I'll
assumes you don't come home you're
[ __ ] R it's fine so there was no
reason to be jealous because we'll
always tell each other right so it's
like and she would tell me plenty of
times so there's no reason together yeah
we live together we had a to rules we
had no no doing it in the door in the in
the dorm in the [ __ ] apartment
yeah and then no Asians and then did
that last that kind of relationship yeah
longer than any relations we ever had
for years and then now you have nobody
I've lots hmm that's right have you guys
heard of is it I don't know if it's
called solo goomy
is it solokha me so look at me yeah
where it's like you're basically um
you're not you don't stop dating people
but you just sort of marry yourself you
marry to the idea of being like a
forever bachelor oh yeah I'm not looking
for like I'm just not looking for that
anymore huh sometimes I am but then it
would mean like I maybe just haven't met
anybody it's like in a while that's how
magical and these guys deep burn yeah
you know Brenna's easy their date I'm
sorry sorry again but you see these
relationship marriages it seemed to be
working
mm-hmm you don't think that that's a
part of your future oh I pity them do
you really yeah I really do with their
kids and everything with the kids also I
see them in their moments their public
like everything's great but I see them
in the moments me too remember reap fry
everything was growing great
everything's going now we love each
other and then they found for divorce
like three days after they said
everything was great yeah no you were
living in hell and have this public like
smile yeah so I what I do is I try to
live my life to make those people
jealous yeah for real I know I can sit
around playing xbox all day doing
nothing like if I'm saying I'll guess
what I'm gonna go to Indonesia for a
month said that you would love to do but
you can't because you have this [ __ ]
kid rah no I'm gonna [ __ ] nines I'm
gonna go out there and [ __ ] do [ __ ]
I'm gonna see the world I live my life
New York in the drop of a hat because
I'm like you know why I'm gonna do you
are [ __ ] so [ __ ] free now we're all
free man yeah oh you you're you're free
to and you can work with them but don't
work for them right ladies and gentlemen
God darn it what a [ __ ] night but
darn it next time I come back we'll do
this again we have to do it again never
we do a question what's its called
unhelpful advice
[Music]